did you have any difference of who you
wanted to fight like her who you would
like to see for your next fight before
the gate Ferguson bout and then after
did that change um you know I always
wanted to get in there with Tony but but
he's injured I believe he broke his
orbital in that fight so he's gonna be
out a little while Gate she's obviously
gonna sit and wait for khabib to be out
of ramadhan and they able to fight again
which I heard them talking about uh July
or August maybe unless seen a couple
tweets about that timeframe so I kind of
knew I thought possibly the loser of
that fight uh I could fight again
you know if gates you would have lost
the rematch would have made sense and
also if Tony would have just lost and
not been injured the rematch or not to
rematch but that fight would have made
sense so I really have no clue what do
you see what direction they're gonna go
man
but I want to fight yeah do you think
it's kind of unfair it seems like
everybody's willing to fight except for
Conor kind of and this look I'm just a
lay person I'm was just a fan and not
even a great I'm and I'm also afraid to
fight people but ah but it seems like
from just a fans point of view that
Conor gets kind of put in this different
not class but he gets a different
treatment kind of a little bit does it
feel like that as a fighter or no yeah
he gets the he gets the pick win and who
and and where he fights and he's done a
great job of maximizing his earning
potential and it is a business right if
he's out there complaining about the
rankings in any other sport what you do
is you compete against the next person
in the rankings to climb yeah so [ __ ]
go yeah are you feeling like um that
it's gonna be hard to cut weight like
were you notice and that as you get
along your career that you're like oh
man that to get down and 155 is gonna be
tough yeah it's very tough the last few
weight cuts were pretty hard the fight
with khabib the weight cut was a little
easier on me because I put so much into
it and focused so much on it
because I thought it was gonna be a
grueling fight and I knew I was
travelling across the world so I just
wanted to make sure I had that part of
the fight camp down so we went the extra
mile and I brought in a nutritionist for
the last few weeks and and we made it
you made every meal for me for the last
few weeks of camp and that really helped
me
it's not easy man getting down to 155 is
very hard for me and so and that's the
only like so for you guys is weight
class that's where you have to fight at
right 155 155 yeah if I jumped up I'd
have to fight 170 pounds and those guys
are even bigger you know those guys are
walking around 200 pounds to shop so
your next fight will you have any
control over that do you have a say-so
in it is the hooker fight still on do
you know you know they wanted us to
fight May 16th then they talked a little
bit about switching our fight to here in
Florida when all the stuff got scrambled
because we were originally supposed to
fight out in California in San Diego
then they were gonna let us fight at a
higher weight class they were gonna let
us fight at 170 because the lack of
preparation and training it just didn't
work out that fight didn't work out it
was rushed I didn't want to you know
fight outside the weight class it was a
bunch of weird things and if they want
to book it I'll fight him you know I
just want to fight right whoever I need
to fight to show these guys that I'm
still the best you know the best the top
in line to get another title shot I want
to fight you know I just need to win
you're ready I'm ready yeah so how many
weeks notice do you think you need to be
ready for a fight or hours dude I'll
tell you what that's like one roll of
toilet paper at the Publix and there's
you know somebody and we're about the
same distance and we start spreading I
mean I'm gonna fight you ready but I do
for weeks give me four weeks I'll be
ready yeah
and that's quicker you know yeah so as
so as right now then so the hooker fight
isn't definite it's not on right now
right now you're anything could happen
anything could happen and but I came to
South Florida mm-hmm you know a week ago
just to start preparing because I knew I
want to fight and I know they're gonna
start pumping out these cards now that
they had their first event back I think
they're gonna keep them rolling and I'm
gonna be ready when an opportunity comes
how soon do you think it could be until
you have a to you and have an idea of
your next bout I actually Saturday night
after the fights I sort of blown up Dana
Dana White John show me you know just
kept texting them they told me I'm
fighting next month so let's go Wow yeah
they didn't tell me you
that's exciting though man that's dope
man what if you and I might have just
gonna like get this crazy past I look at
my phone yet you'll fight tomorrow
there's not even a fight card tomorrow
what what have you been doing during the
quarantine I know you've been staying
busy training cuz I'll check on you I'll
see your videos on IG and stuff what
else what else have you been up to
besides training well I've only been
here a week so I've been home with my
family for the most part since I got
here I've just been training and playing
PlayStation but my wife and daughter
come to meet me this weekend so I'm home
and two weeks is my limit I can't do two
weeks without oh yeah and any new little
Poirier kids on the books or what man
y'all got another little one in the oven
no not yet but uh it's coming yeah when
you know shoot for a boy can't really
pick it but we'll see what happens yeah
I know you love being a day a man Sweet
Pea looks pretty damn tough though she
is pretty tough she likes to wrestle man
I bought our trampoline
you know the trampoline with the cage
around it yeah of course you look man of
course you and your family you put a
cage around anything man you guys are
ready to go so so but overall do you
feel like just watching those fights
hell the night it just really got you
amped up and ready to rock huh
yeah I I went to sleep Saturday night
and woke up Sunday more focused I felt
like something clicked you know I got my
my calendar I started writing stuff down
started writing a time frame down went
for a run
woke up early today got my whole day
plan cooked my food for the day I
started a diet you know I'm ready let's
go let's go oh um were you shocked at
UFC was like the first sport back I know
they wanted to man I know Dana's a
trailblazer and he likes to set records
and and and be the first to do things
and I really thought he was gonna do it
I thought it was gonna be the other card
that got canceled in April I believe he
thought they were gonna go through with
that I just know Dana have already
pushes and and rallies to get things
going and but he is his first sport back
man yeah word man well uh in a paper who
you know in a time where everybody's
home and everybody's still cheering from
the NFL Draft you know if they're
getting that kind of ratings I'm sure
the pay-per-view did well I know huh do
you um I had a question what happens if
if d if DC fights are in Ghana
oh I don't know man I don't know
we saw steep a outwrestle inconnue but
that was a little bit you know a little
while back you know Daniel is a he's a
heavyweight but he's not a big guy he is
not he's like my height he might be an
inch taller than me Wow yeah yeah and
and in Ghana is a is a huge human being
dude he's big and I'm friends with
Daniel he can get it done but that's you
know one mistake in you but he was a
Strikeforce Grand Prix heavyweight
champion you know he beat up a bunch of
other former champions to win that belt
that in Ghana guys scary though man dude
man his arms are like long cars he has
like limousines in his arms rut you say
that they said like his punching power
was equal to like a Ford Taurus or
something so I don't know am I'll do the
numbers blue I guess that's a pretty
good car to be compared to that's a lot
man um have you ever have you been on
Mike Tyson's podcast no I mean I would
love to go I would love to go yeah it
seemed like something you would uh that
you would be like and read yeah that
Tyson rants bro
after the fight man he serving the
salads of marijuana and I'm over there
bro UFC in boxing world obviously you
know cross paths sometimes have you have
you heard anything about a Tyson come
back I heard some rumblings of him maybe
join a bare-knuckle fighting and AM yeah
bro that's rude up into a few of their
shows up into one I here in Miami and
I've been to one in Mississippi and dude
that's hard to watch man and I love
fights and I've been to thousands of
fights sitting ringside and watching
these guys bunk knuckles it's does it
take you back to all does it take you
back to a time like in the beginning of
your career or it is it just a totally
different ballgame yeah it's a you know
I've never fought bare-knuckle only in
street fights you know but I've never
fought a sanctioned bare-knuckle fight
only at Mardi Gras I'll do it yeah
that's why don't go to Mardi Gras yeah
in Louisiana right yeah you too many
guys wanna uh too many fake Mike Perry's
want to show up you know
yeah yeah I don't want them problems man
I don't know but I know they a
bare-knuckle also fight assigned to
former world champion Shannon Briggs a
guy out here in Florida so if Tyson does
sign to bare-knuckle I mean these are
two legitimate heavyweight champions of
the world that could fight bare-knuckle
would be it would be madness Wow
that'd be crazy to see Tyson
bare-knuckle dude he's 50 something
years old
Oh yup it looks like right the way he's
moving oh man each one of his knuckles
is like a fist they say yeah powers the
last thing to go real aging as a fighter
yet powers the last thing to go damn and
that's what he had the most of all power
yeah
well cool may have best of luck dude I
hope you have a good time over there
with your family in Florida man and
excited to see you in the ring man
hopefully as soon as a month yeah they
said next month so somebody's gonna be
okay man Dustin the diamond 48 thanks so
much champ we'll see you soon yes sir
thank you brother being good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one